hi everyone
Sal Khan here welcome to the daily
homeroom for those of you all who don't
know what this is showing up off of
Facebook or YouTube this is something
that we started once we started seeing
math school closures and it's really a
way for all of us to stay connected
obviously Khan Academy as a
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing free world-class education for
anyone anywhere over the last many years
we've been building resources that we've
saw students use both outside of school
and inside of school with teachers and
we could have never foreseen this crisis
but when it started happening we
realized given our mission it's our duty
to step up in any way possible
to support you the student the teacher
and the parent and so we've been putting
out webinars to help parents and
teachers get set up
we've been issuing daily schedules we
just issued some learning plans last
week and we also thought it would be fun
to have something like this just a way
to stay connected in times of social
distancing and talk about interesting
subjects it might be really the Khan
Academy it might be education generally
it might be just how do we make you know
how do we navigate this this crisis that
we're going through I will give my the
plug that I give every day remind
everyone that we are supported through
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
please think about donating I want to
give a special shout out to several
corporations who stepped up in the last
few weeks
Bank of America stepped up that first
weekend when it was clear that we're
gonna have the school closings
google.org 18t Novartis if any of you
represent corporations please reach out
to us we were running a deficit even
before this crisis and our costs have
gone up since then and there's all sorts
of things we want to do and accelerate
forward but we're only going to be able
to do it if we're able to get more
support and thank you for the many
thousands of people who've donated over
the last few weeks it all makes a
difference and allows us to accelerate
our work so the focus of today I have a
very fun guest who's a close friend of
mine and also does very important work
in the world we have Jim Steyer from
Common Sense Media hi Jim I said how
great to be here and it should get me to
Khan Academy it is a fabulous
organization and it's tires are donors
we're not for a problem nobody
better than Salim Khan Academy he's
right about that I did not tell Jim to
say that but that's why we are friends
you know you know so first one this
company I'm gonna ask him a few
questions about Common Sense Media
generally and and and maybe some of the
things we're doing together and how
we're navigating the crisis but if
anyone has questions feel free to go to
on YouTube and Facebook and our team
members will surface questions if you
have questions for Jim about his work at
Common Sense Media or any questions for
me as well but it may be a good place to
start tell folks what common sense media
is and why you started it okay so we are
a nonprofit organization and really the
leading kids media and advocacy
organization in the u.s. I started it
because I'm a former schoolteacher and a
Stanford prof who cares a ton about
really educating families and kids in
general but also about the impact of
media and technology on their lives
I started it 15 years ago we do three
things we H educate and advocate so for
folks out there in the audience who know
us we made every movie TV video game
website book music you name it common
sense rates it and gives you information
so parents can make better choices for
their kids the educate part of our work
is we created the field of digital
citizenship digital literacy so we have
a curriculum at most of the schools in
the United States about the safe ethical
responsible use of media and technology
at home and in the classroom and then
finally we're a leading child advocacy
group that advocates for everything like
everybody having Wi-Fi and broadband
every student America having access to
Khan Academy these kind of resources and
also in issues like education and
healthcare and all the issues that
matter to kids and families here in the
u.s. so a big nonprofit just like Khan
Academy and a huge fan of Khan Academy
itself you know we're fans of you and
all of the work you all do as well and
so to make it tangible for a lot of
folks you know I use common sense media
with my own family when I'm just trying
to find good stuff for them for you know
we're doing movie nights once a week now
with with all the
the social distancing and we return to
common sense media a lot for that what
are some of the things I know we have
some stuff going on together as well but
where's where what were y'all focused on
before this crisis hit and how is that
evolved to some degree since then
okay great crescents out so basically
before the crisis hit we had this big
consumer platform with 100 million
people on it trying to figure out what
movies to watch for their kids on movie
night or what video games were
appropriate for a 12 year old etc and we
were in most of the schools in the u.s.
basically working with teachers and
educators saying here's how to use the
internet here's how to use cell phones
and social media in a really responsible
way and when this crisis head of one of
the first things we thought were like
wow we need to work with Khan Academy
but we also thought wouldn't it be great
to create one central hub where schools
could go and where families could go to
find at one click of a button the best
educational resources to deal with the
cogut 19 crisis so along with the
support of folks like Khan Academy we
created wide open school.org which is
this new platform our colleagues at
amplify helped build the platform and
then honestly we linked to the best
content out there Khan Academy National
Geographic Sesame Street etc and the
idea was make it really easy for parents
and students who are at home and we're
doing different learning and also for
schools around the United States to have
one central place where they could get
the content they wanted and actually to
do home schooling and if you mentioned
Sal having a daily schedule and you
there it's really really important
because everybody's at home right now
and trying to do learning from home and
whether they're on Khan Academy or wide
open school it's just we're just trying
to help everybody learn from home and we
think this is going to be changing the
nature of Education long term just like
Khan Academy changed the nature of
Education when Sal found at Khan Academy
well what's your sense you know a lot of
questions I'm having a lot of
conversations DC and obviously about the
whole virus generally
but how do you think how do you think
this is going to play out over the next
several weeks or months especially in
relation to school and and kids maybe
generally speaking I actually we're here
in California South so you know we've
had a governor really step forward and
mayors and stuff I think we're gonna be
sad to say I think we're gonna be
learning from home for the rest of the
school year for sure and I think that
even for the rest of 2020 much of
learning is going to be online much more
than normal
and therefore everybody out there is
going to need to be able to access the
Internet it's going to be able to access
resources like Khan Academy and so I
think this is gonna last longer than
normal and I think it's really important
for all of us I have four children shall
I know you're a dick doting dad do you
know I think we have to explain to our
kids that we're gonna be at home it's
good family time but we're gonna need to
figure out how to do school also how to
take breaks and get exercise and not sit
in front of a screen all day long so I
think this is gonna last longer than we
think I think for example it's gonna
probably affect summers and a lot of us
are gonna probably do some more at home
than we were planning on I know my my
kids who are little older than York
itself they are you know some in college
and grad school and they're taking their
classes at home and I their summer jobs
have changed
so I sad to say hey I think we're gonna
have to figure out how to work with this
over the months I don't think it's gonna
be weeks I think it'll be a few months
to be honest because they've been virus
yeah
and we're getting some comments off of
you to zetas RORO says I had been using
this with my kids I think they're
referring to either common sense or wide
open school and I've been using this my
kids this week and it helps me feel less
guilty about screen time actually that's
an interesting issue how do you think
about coping with screen time guilt I'm
happy to give my own views on that I'm
although I'm conflicted what what are
your thoughts as a parent and an expert
so I actually I'd love to hear what you
think juice al as a parent and an expert
so definitely you're gonna have more
screen time right now there's just no
question because literally my kids are
going to school online right now so
they're going to be in
the screen more than they are and and
and as common sense where the leading
spokespeople on this issue about you
know balance and moderation when it
comes to screen timing by the way it's a
really important message but I think
that we have to understand these are
unique circumstances
so I do think that we should let up on
some of the hard and fast rules we want
our kids going to school going on online
learning we want to using Khan Academy
resources but I think you also as a
parent for example really want to have
balance in your kid's life and you don't
want to plunk them in front of the
screen for eight hours in a row that's
my take and that's what we're trying to
do with the star children how about you
though what do you think I feel very
similarly you know I've always my answer
even before this crisis was it's not so
much measuring what is happening on the
screen but it's happening with measuring
what's happening in the students whole
life and so if a student is getting time
where they're socializing spending time
with their family they're running
outside they have time for creativity
etc then I'm less worried about that
screen time especially if that screen
time is constructive screen time I think
most of us if we saw our middle school
students spend three hours composing a
poem we would view that as negative
screen time or if we saw them you know I
thought I'm a big fan of reading a book
for real but I know a lot of people like
reading on a Kindle that's not the end
of the world type of screen time if
someone wants to you know I remember
when I was a kid if I got really excited
about some I actually didn't have a
computer at home growing up but I at the
local university I somehow convinced a
professor to give me access to the
computers but you know there were times
where I spent 12 hours straight 20 hours
straight just creating something coding
something and that was I mean it was
probably a little unhealthy I probably
had more caffeine than I should have but
I was actually constructive screen time
and obviously if you're learning and so
yeah I'm trying to bounce it myself and
especially in this time of social
distancing and everyone is together you
know yesterday me and the family were
all on the couch together we had the
popcorn going we watched two episodes of
Will Smith's documentary that's on
Disney Plus around one strange Rock that
was great I thought that was great
screen time and great family time we
learned a ton about aliens and
astronauts and how life happened to
exist on
on earth so I think that kind of thing
when you're with your family we're
having a good conversation around it it
was two hours of screen time with TV
watching but I felt like it was you know
a lot of a lot of bonding too so yeah
there's a balance I agree with you I
mean I actually think that's what I
would say I think it's quantity and
quality and you're absolutely right and
the other thing about this code 19
epidemic is it forces more family time
which is a really good thing I mean your
kids are a little younger than ours your
guys you know tell and so for me I have
kids who are teenagers and college age
and a little older right and it's great
because you actually are spending more
time as a family you know you're having
family dinners um but I do think that
there's it's when you talk about screen
time you should think about quality in
terms of do good stuff like just like
you just got family screen time but
educational stuff if you're gonna read a
book online that's great not too much is
just junk if you will it's sort of like
food and you're thinking about your
nutritional diet you don't want to have
your kid only have junk food um but it's
also taking breaks
you mentioned exercising getting outside
as much as possible getting a break sort
of having about there that by the daily
schedule that we were talking about is
important and it's balanced moderation
but we're gonna be in front of screens
more often so let's make it constructive
quality screen time why not yeah and
there's a couple questions we have for
Amy Liang on YouTube as asking what
inspired you to make the website Jim
sigh well maybe i'll brought it in the
the question a little bit what what you
know as you pointed used to be a
Stanford professor you're a lawyer by
training what what did you see 15 years
ago where you said hey there's something
wrong with society we need a
not-for-profit like Common Sense Media
so my life work I've been asking for
professor and now I'm dating myself but
for 30 years and so and I was a civil
rights lawyer first though he's correct
and what happened was I wanted to create
the most important child advocacy group
in United States I'm really an advocate
my life work is as an educator teacher
and it's an advocate for children that's
really what I do and when we started
when I started common sense
we created the web platform the platform
and all the ratings and reviews and all
that stuff basically to get the public
to care about children and also we
realized at that time this is 15 years
ago that movies and TV shows and music
were having a huge impact on kids lives
their families life remember there was
no iPhone no Facebook no Google no
snapchat nothing and in the day when we
started calming censor is basically
movies and TV and maybe music and video
games and but alright the real thing for
me was to build a platform that
everybody could join if they wanted to
care about children generally and to
create this membership-based sort of
advocacy group for children particularly
for disadvantaged children who don't
have a voice and lo and behold 15 years
later oh my gosh
who knew that we would have 100 million
plus users for for our consumer reports
guide and and the truth is I didn't
realize the media technology piece would
be so big and who could have known that
Steve Jobs would bring out the iPhone or
that Mark Zuckerberg would invent
Facebook or that you'd have YouTube and
snapchat and all the other things that
are so key acted Bible but the truth is
when it happened common sense was there
and we give it and so I remember when
you start at Khan Academy and I remember
those conversations we had and I was so
happy that you decided to make Khan
Academy and not-for-profit because you
could have built a successful core
private business but your heart was so
much in Irvine ever forget that your
heart was so much in the right place of
doing this as a not-for-profit and
making it to school for everybody in the
world and you should be very proud of
that my friend I'm serious
but that's why we love working with you
guys but I could have never predicted 15
years ago that common sense would have
gotten this big but the same mission is
about kids basically its how do you
change the world for kids how do you
improve the world for kids particularly
the ones who need it the most that's my
biggest concern by the way jerk oh good
19 crisis is how do we take care of the
kids who are not living who are newer in
a two-room home with five people and
who's whose school isn't even doing
learning yet because they don't even
a system setup so I think for those of
us we're so fortunate I think it's
really important to remember that
there's like tens of millions of kids
out there who have very few resources
and we want to care about them and give
them the same opportunities that out
cons kids and Kim stires kids have but
that's what motivates me that's why I
started common sense and like you who
knew Khan Academy would turn it you were
just making videos for your nieces and
nephews look what Apple sort of the same
thing with common sense no you never you
never know and there's a question here
from Facebook Scott yang who's been
consistently asking good questions
I mean I'm gonna broaden his question
his question is our video games fine but
I'm gonna broaden it which is obviously
common sense
you guys are rating what is good what's
appropriate for different ages and I
think all of us have a sense you know
you see a video game where you're
shooting people up like hey that might
not be right I mean frankly even for me
myself if I watch a movie that's or
video game that's really gruesome I'm
like you know this when I was a teenager
for some reason I didn't mind it but now
when I look at it I don't know I'm like
oh that's that's troubling I'm not sure
if I can sleep tonight what what do we
and then there's things like social
media and things that aren't gruesome
but have other dynamics yeah what do we
there's stuff we know intuitively but
what do we what evidence do we have that
it is maybe some of this stuff could
cause harm we know it's really a good
question so video games have been a big
issue for common sense right from day
one right so we were the first people we
started rating them and really calling
out the violence in certain of the old
video games and and and and explaining
to parents and educators that you know
too much violence is really bad for kids
that there's copycat violence and
there's and also you can become an ear
device so I would sixth really
interesting we because we realize how
incredibly popular video games are and
they remain to be that day I have a 16
year old son who if we allowed him to
would play video games for 18 hours a
day and not all of them would be the
video games that I might recommend and
so I think a couple of things we worked
very closely with the video game
industry could tell about you have to
limit the violence also there needs to
be racially stereotypical stuff and a
lot of sexist stuff there's a lot of
content and video
that was certainly inappropriate for an
eight-year-old or a tendril and then
there was the issue of too much time in
front of a screen so we get we have done
a lot of advocacy around the issue of
video games we've done a lot to educate
parents and teachers about how much time
kids love video how much time kids are
spending playing video games and also
how to find the good ones because as you
know souther for a ton of great games
out there and there are different kinds
of learning some of the most creative
educational products are actually game
based products that are really
educational so again I think it's both
quality of the game and amount so I
wouldn't let Jesse our son play 10 hours
of video games even though he probably
would like to um and you're right
teenagers particularly boys are the ones
who would spend all day in front of a
video game machine if we let them but
it's a great question and I think it's
one of the reasons why Common Sense
don't get such a good resource because
you can go there and check out anything
and say hey is this okay for my age or
older my 15 year old and it's balanced
it's moderation but video games can also
be awesome and you know I like to play
em jus but I'm not nearly as talented as
my son is and what about social media
you know I hear at least anecdotally
I've talked to university presidents
they're talking about how anxiety has
gotten through the roof and some people
have pointed it to this is a generation
that kind of grew up in so on social
media what do you all know about that
well that's a really big issue so first
of all this is the first real generation
of digital natives who are growing up on
social media platforms and so I think we
try to take a fairly balanced approach
we have been critical of some of the big
social media players for allowing
inappropriate content on their platform
whether it's cyberbullying or you know
the one thing about some of the
platforms if you think about say
Instagram and snapchat would you're
where a lot of kids are today there's a
constant comparison of yourself I wrote
a book back in 2012 called talking back
to Facebook where I talked about the
fact that the father of two daughters
that millions of girls out there and
boys do Photoshop their images on
Facebook and
and snapchat meaning they're wanting to
show an ideal personality or an ideal
image which is just unrealistic so we've
tried to work closely with the big
platforms and tried to get them to clean
up some of the stuff that's on it and be
aware of how many hundreds of millions
of kids are on those platforms but the
truth is this you know I know as a
father of teenagers kids are on those
platforms the question is how do you
both limit the amount of time and also
use those platforms for the good stuff
and I think this is an as a parent you
really have to talk with your kids about
social media and teachers do too much to
the curriculum that we have in schools
around the United States and globally is
about how do you deal with social media
how do you use it responsibly and how do
you not engage in bullying or all the
other kinds of things that can negative
on an open source we depart and we're
very frank with the guys who run the
biggest platforms do about trying to
clean up those platforms and make them
kid-friendly and appropriate too so that
I think that the big do have you found
that folks have been receptive to that
to your feedback
it depends I will be I honestly you know
so I really will say this it depends on
the platform in the company I think a
lot of it has to do with who the people
are to lead the organization because
it's the same thing in a way at the end
of the day there are a ton of great
people who work at Khan Academy but you
set the tone and the culture you do and
there's a degree to which I do that at
common sense so I think when it comes to
that it really depends platform but I
think that's really true in life that
you have to show leadership just like as
a parent and you and your spouse have to
set the family role models and yet they
set good examples for your kid
it's including about media technologies
but I think that some of the platforms
have been more responsive than others
you know the other thing is it's funny
because as a Stanford professor I've had
so many thousands of students who went
into the technology industry I think
that people who work in the tech
industry have to realize the incredible
impact of the platform's they built on
the lives of everybody out there and
they have to be responsible for the
content of those platforms and also some
of the design
platforms so that you don't have people
sitting there watching you know nine
hours in a row of the of their favorite
show so I think it's really about I
think if there's a big role for for
common sense folks like you selling all
of us and parents and kids out there to
ask the platform's to be responsible and
and I think one of the things about this
crisis is a lot of them have really
stepped up to the plate and if you look
at the partners with wide open school
haven't just been you guys but you know
Google and zoom have been really good at
Apple and that's been great because it's
such huge reach and they oh I really
feel they have a responsibility to pull
public to do right by the public and I
think that in a number of cases they're
really stepping up and should and
they're gonna need to do that long-term
as education becomes increasingly online
and learn at home Justin for any kind of
stuff yeah and in fairness to them and
it is these are incredibly hard issues
and obviously we are right now streaming
on YouTube Facebook so we're able to
leverage social media for hopefully not
evil and even you know some of the
things that are not optimal about it you
know there are all these really
interesting edge cases around free
speech or how do you control things or
if you have some machine learning
algorithm that's optimizing for views
how do you control that so I definitely
understand where some of their
difficulties live but it is it's it's a
real thing I you know I've you know when
we talk to university people running
universities and high schools right now
the amount of anxiety and depression
from kids to your point comparing
themselves to others or getting bullied
or bullying others is seems a little bit
out of control well I don't want to end
on that note well Jim why do you tell
what what are your hopes what are your
hopes for Common Sense Media what what
are your hopes for what might happen in
the the coming months ahead or coming
years ahead I you know right before we
got on we were talking a little bit
about whether we could get to a world of
universal at-home Internet access
what are you know send on a high note if
you're still there
well maybe maybe maybe Jim has
disappeared so anyway I'll thank Jim for
joining I thought that was really
valuable and we were able to get 90% of
what who you were hoping to get to get
from get from Jim they do really great
work at common sense and I encourage any
of y'all with more questions we have a
little bit more time I'm always happy to
answer these these questions I think
there are there's actually a lot of
questions see someone asked this is
Nikhil go vendor ask for both myself and
Jim how the social media had a positive
and negative effect on your life I would
say social media for me personally has
for the most part been a positive effect
on my life obviously the early days of
Khan Academy and people think Khan
Academy started with videos we actually
started with a this little software
platform that I was running for my
cousins and I made videos to to
supplement that software but obviously
having if you consider YouTube to be a
social media platform having a place
where I could publish and people
discover allowed people to discover Khan
Academy allowed some of the first
funders to realize that this was an
effort worth doing so I think Khan
Academy's been affirmed that we
obviously still leverage social media a
lot we're doing it right now
but I would also say that I'm fortunate
and I do consider myself fortunate that
you know I didn't in the same way grow
up with social media I could imagine the
things that Jim is talking about when
you're 12 you know 13 years old 14 year
old or you're a 10 year old with a fake
account pretending you're 13 years old
that it can it can put a lot of pressure
on you to try to be something you're not
or when your frontal lobe isn't fully
developed you might be putting things
out there into the world that later you
might be not so proud of it's good it's
good that you know for a lot of us we
were lucky enough that it wasn't
documented on on social media and I
think that can also lead lead to some
stresses you know generally in my own
personal life I've gotten a lot of
people saying hey Sal you have to get on
Twitter more you got a post on Instagram
more and I think like the the 17 or 18
year old Sal or the 20 year old Sal
actually would have loved doing that or
said look at this really deep thing I
have to say and I but I think these days
I feel a little bit maybe overexposed
I'm like well I know people really don't
need that
weird thing that I'm I'm thinking about
right now but you know overall I think
social media can be a very positive
thing but but you just have to be
careful Jim people were asking how is
social media
personally that better or better what
about yourself has social media been a
positive or negative or or and how for
you Jim
you know it's interesting I think what
you just said it's so intelligent
I think it's been overall a positive you
know it's interesting because there's a
parent I've been a lot of times when I
was concerned about particularly my kids
when they were younger about some of
them bullying but also that comparison
you know I mentioned the body image
issue um me I'm not a big user of social
media myself but I think it to me it's
all about how you use it it's like if
you use it wisely and in balance and
moderation use it for the good things
social media can be incredible if you
use it for negative things to be hurtful
to other people or to worry about to
play out your identity it can be
traveling it's a it's a it's an ongoing
effort for me as a parent but I'm I I
think we have a huge role and you have a
huge role in educating our own kids
about it first and foremost setting a
good role I would say that the parents
the number one thing you do is try to be
a good role model right you have to
model that for your kids if you're
bullying other people online or on a
social media platform or texting nasty
things to people even it's an adult
don't do that that's not good but you
know this is the world we live in I'm
glad I didn't grow up with it I'm glad I
grew up in an era where you know you
just didn't have it but now I think it's
all about using it and using common
sense ya know it's a good way to end and
I will add I've had moment you know a
lot of what has driven in my life is my
attempts to help my cousins and I
there's been a couple of moments over
the last few years where I literally
would call up a cousin and I was like do
you realize that I and the whole world
can see that picture that someone took
of you in that situation
take it down future employers will see
it this is not going to be good for you
and so I think a lot of folks don't
realize that someone takes out their
phone take
a picture of you and something you know
doing something silly and it's out there
and it's actually really hard to get it
out and and your employers will see it
you know your future in-laws will see it
you have to be yeah you you have to be
very careful and I think a lot of young
people don't realize that it's not just
the the here and now there's long term
implications so yeah be very very very
careful of all of these things so Jim no
better person than yourself to talk
about social media and and media
generally thanks for joining and thanks
for your partnership on all of what
we're trying to do for to support
families so honestly my honor to be here
I am such a huge fan of Khan Academy and
of yours personally and I but I would
say the same thing good luck as a dad
just like good luck to me as a dad
during these crazy times but we are huge
fans and I'm gonna end by saying what
you would I say at the beginning you
guys should all support Khan Academy it
is like this incredible institution
not-for-profits started by one of the
best people I've ever known so bless you
think it was an honor to be here itself
I will look forward to working with you
for many years to come
great thanks Jim and stay safe take care
of the family you all right well thanks
everyone for joining it was a fun
conversation and please continue to join
us for I'll see you on Monday with our
next daily live stream
you